one two three four
there's been so many times where we're
told that movies are just make-believe
but that's not always the case not
everything in the movies we watch
is fabricated in fact the filmmakers and
stars of many of your favorite films
will often go to extreme lengths to make
their films feel as real as possible
from shaving one's head to skydiving
this is when what happened on screen
actually happened on set oh i love it
martin scorsese's award-winning black
comedy is one of the craziest
and most memorable movies to date and
for good reasons
during the film's notorious office party
scene involving an almost naked marching
band
one of the things that can be seen in
the background is a woman getting her
hair completely shaved off her head
what you may not know is that actually
happened on set
the name of the woman is natasha newman
a hair stylist and long time friend of
star leonardo dicaprio
newman actually volunteered for her head
to be shaved something that surprised
the film's producers
[Applause]
ratatouille is one of pixar's most
beloved films though what you may not
know
is some of the lengths that some of the
creative team took to make a film about
a talking rat who can cook
a bit more real for the scene where
linguine dives into a river in his
chef's uniform to rescue remy
the animation team wanted to figure out
what parts of the outfit would stick to
the body
this led to crew member kesten migdal to
dress as a cook and jump into a pool
in order for the crew to make the
animation feel more realistic
but we're together on this pixar's soul
is one of their most philosophical films
yet
and despite the fantastical world built
in the film the filmmakers wanted to
make sure that it could still have some
accuracy
the first soul that is counted in the
film is 108 billion
210 million 121 415
the writers of this pixar hit had
actually consulted with the population
reference bureau
to get this number meaning that there
really has been over 108 billion humans
in the history of the planet
soul number 108 billion two hundred ten
million one hundred twenty one thousand
four hundred and fifteen friends is
arguably one of the most well-known
sitcoms of all time
and it's clear just how passionate the
cast was when the show was on air
in the season seven episode of the show
titled the one with joey's new brain
we learned that ross actually plays the
bagpipes what you may not know is that
actor david schwimmer
actually learned to play the bagpipes
for the episode to top that off in the
scene where ross plays for phoebe and
rachel
jennifer aniston went off script and
started giggling as lisa kudrow sang
along to the sound of ross's bagpipes
bagpipes are appropriate for our wedding
why not because we hate them working
with child actors can be difficult
such was the case with the creative team
behind monsters inc
when trying to get five-year-old mary
gibbs to record her lines for the iconic
role of
boo they eventually found an effective
solution
instead of having gibbs stuck in a
recording booth the crew followed her
around with a microphone
and recorded her talking as she played
the results were spectacular with
audiences
all over the world falling in love with
boo
what the notebook is arguably the most
popular nicholas sparks movie to date
and starred ryan gosling and rachel
mcadams
just as they were becoming a-list stars
gosling decided to go with his role as
noah and just like the character he
decided to start building furniture
the same furniture that gosling built
was actually used in the film for the
scene
set in the house that noah built for
ally i'm a married woman
not yet stockard channing's rizzo is a
favorite among fans of the hit musical
grease
though fans may be surprised to learn
that the hickeys she has throughout the
film
are actually real the hickeys were
created by jeff conaway who played
channing's on-screen boyfriend kaniki
conaway told the film's crew that a
hickey from kenickie had to be given by
him
from me pinkie lee this oscar-nominated
true life thriller
is quite the intense experience the
pivotal scene which features hank's
title character being treated by a medic
after being rescued from the somalian
pirates
is one of the film's most
heart-wrenching scenes director paul
greengrass went the extra mile when
directing the scene
by casting danielle albert an actual
navy medic
greengrass had told albert to treat the
scene as a regular military exercise
leading the scene to be entirely
improvised can you tell me what's going
on
in the climactic concert scene of the
hit 2003 comedy freaky friday
we see jamie lee curtis rocking out on
the guitar
but just like david schwimmer playing
the bagpipes curtis
actually was playing the guitar on the
screen while doing
press for the film curtis claimed that
learning to play the guitar was one of
her favorite parts about making the film
this ultimately paid off as curtis's
performance in the film
won over critics and audiences alike and
even earned her several award
nominations
well what am i supposed to do margot
robbie received universal acclaim for
her oscar-nominated performance as
disgraced figure skater tanya harding
robbie was extremely committed to the
role and revealed that she did her own
skating for a majority of the movie
she even went as far as to train four
hours a day five days a week over the
course of five months so she could
perfect harding's skating style
she goes out and gives a beautiful skate
this disney plus drama is based off the
true story of teenager zak
zobiak who wrote and performed a
chart-topping song while battling an
aggressive form of cancer
sobiak's family and friends were excited
about a film that celebrated his legacy
and contributed heavily to the film and
even were on set for most of the filming
the soviet family had even donated
zack's real clothes for star fin
argus to wear throughout filming hello
stillwater
the first season of netflix dramedy
received some criticism for its lack of
actors on the spectrum for a
show that's themed around autism
showrunner rabia rashid tried to make up
for this in the second season of the
show
and casted actors who were actually
atypical for the scenes where sam
attends a support group
for people with autism it was because of
this choice that the second season was
much more well received and received
praise for its representation
no chicken fingers that sounds awful you
shouldn't go
elf has become a holiday staple for many
thanks to will ferrell's energetic
performance as buddy the elf
it may come as a surprise to fans that
the scenes of buddy interacting with
everyday new yorkers was entirely
unscripted and many of the people he
interacts with were not actors
what may be the craziest of all is that
farrell really did eat gum
off the city sidewalks in one of the
film's most infamous gags
the guy in the red jogging suit santa
sit
that guy was just there just like elf
home alone is a holiday classic that is
beloved by many
in the scene towards the end of the film
where harry threatens to bite off
kevin's fingers
you may be shocked to learn that joe
pesci really did bite macaulay culkin's
finger
albeit by accident kolkan even claims
that he still has a scar from where
pesci bit him
he had broke the skin and everything i'm
a little nine-year-old boy and he's
going around biting him
out of all the actors who perform their
own stunts tom cruise may just be the
most well known
as he loves to please his fans with some
spectacular stunt work
in this high octane sequence from the
sixth entry in the mission impossible
franchise
cruz performed his most impressive stunt
to date
by actually performing a halo jump and
was skydiving at 200 miles per hour
without a harness
this scene ended up being one of the
main highlights of the film for many
to the target open your shoot when the
system says not before and definitely
not after
as you've seen filmmakers and actors
will go to pretty big lengths to make
their movie
as authentic as possible for the sake of
entertainment
whether it be hickeys ice skating or
even
eating gum off the streets of new york
these creative minds went above and
beyond
what's your favorite scene from a movie
that wasn't actually staged